i am never flying your airline are you
out of your damned mine that's crazy i
didn't
find that you'd be crazy to fly that
airline corporate america's embrace of
wokeness it's gonna boomerang on them in
a major way and it's happening across
the spectrum because again
these ships are slow to turn these
corporate ships they're very slow to
turn and once they've decided to steer
into the head storm that is wokeness
it's going to take them a while to get
out of it and not easily because they've
decided to surrender themselves to the
alligator hoping they will be eaten last
this leads to the most bizarre corporate
endorsement of wokeness of the day
that is united airlines so united
airlines put out a video suggesting
that they are going to ensure that half
of their pilots are going to be women or
people of color
now this is crazy it is crazy
because if there is one job in america
there are many jobs in america where
skills should be like the soul qualifies
qualifica
qualification qualifying detail in fact
every job in america i believe skill
should be the only qualifying detail i
don't think that race or sex or sexual
none of that should matter can you do
the job is the only question i want
answered
in every job scenario but if you're
going to pick jobs
where skill is like the only thing that
matters
this would be one of them like personal
life experience does not matter
when you're talking about can you land a
plane safely
and this is like it to me it's like a
heart surgeon do i care about the
personal life experiences of my heart
surgeon
absolutely not absolutely not and but
united
has now made it its goal to say that 50
of its trained pilots are going to be
women
or people of color so pilot stacey
abrams on the line from united airlines
here we go from united airlines
departure view is looking at the plate
everything checks good we're going to
just nab it out then airplane setup for
us to actually fly navigation all the
way out for the hour and after
by 2030 we plan to train 5 000 pilots we
plan for 50
of admitted students to be women or
people of color
partner organizations will help identify
and recruit top
talent and now they've been trying this
in silicon valley for years it turns out
it's a giant fail
the reason it's a giant fail is because
people are either qualified or
unqualified
to be engineers and people are either
qualified or unqualified to be pilots
if you're changing the qualifications
from can you fly a plane to what color
is your skin and do you have
a vagina although i understand that that
is not even a qualification to be a
woman anymore so
do you self-identify as a woman or
are you a person with more melanin in
your skin if those are your
qualifications for your pilot
number one you're going to be subjected
to a discrimination lawsuit like nothing
you've ever seen and number two
i am never flying your airline are you
out of your damned mind why would i get
on a plane
where the only thing i know about the
pilot is that the pilot
may have been select i have a one in two
chance of having a pilot selected not on
the basis of skill alone
that's crazy i didn't find that you'd be
crazy to fly that airline
what what are you doing what are you say
i mean
matt walsh made the uh made the
hilarious point he said you know it
turns out that a certain percentage
of americans are blind and a huge
percentage of americans are elderly
we should have a certain number united
needs to make sure that a certain number
of pilots are qualified
despite being blind and 100 years old it
needs to happen
or alternatively you could not collapse
to the woke idiocy culture
but again our corporate culture has
decided that this is the wave of the
future
they are going to be sorely mistaken
they are going to feel the backlash in a
serious way not just because people stop
flying their airlines but because
competitors will arise who don't follow
this garbage
also because again your protectors on
the in
on the corporate side should be neutral
rules
that foster free markets that of course
is where you succeeded in the first
place
if you decide to undermine those neutral
rules of free marketplaces
by going for the corporatist
the the corporatist crony capitalist
dollars that the democrats are offering
you
get ready man they are not it this is so
short-sighted it is so unbelievably
short-sighted mitch mcconnell put that
point out he said you know corporate
america you might want to not do this
because there are going to be some
consequences for you
my warning if you will to corporate
america is to stay out of politics
it's not what you're designed for
and don't be intimidated by the left
into taking up causes
that put you right in the middle of one
of america's greatest political
debates so that's that's my admonition
and
delta and the other coca-cola and the
other companies that
basically
responded to this partisan appeal
are doing the same thing you know
republicans drink coca-cola too
okay and that of course is a paraphrasal
line that michael jordan once used in
the 1990s the republicans buy sneakers
too it's true
we do and i am not in favor of boycotts
as a general rule i think it's better if
we were able to just patronize whichever
businesses
we think make the best products but so
long as they're going to spit in our
face
well there will be a lot of republicans
who say no we're not doing that anymore
if harry's razors decides that it's
going to withdraw advertising from some
of our shows
well get ready we'll launch our razer
brand and then we'll go right after
the same audience that you advertised in
order to gain access to
okay this works both ways they're going
too far the backlash is coming
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content